JEFF: Well, thank you
guys for joining us again
for another guest chefs at LA.
Today, I think we're all
very excited to have Chef Jet
Tila here with us
who's going to show us
how to master the perfect Pad
Thai and some drunken noodles.
You guys who may
have seen Chef Jet,
we were talking a
little bit earlier
about the YouTube videos.
You may have seen
him on Iron Chef.
You may have seen him on
Chopped, Cutthroat Kitchen.
And when you can't
find him there,
I think you can find him at
the Charleston in Santa Monica,
So--
JET TILA: That's right.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
Thank you, Chef Jet.
JET TILA: Thank you very much.
You can clap, it's OK.
Very much, Jeff.
Appreciate it.
This has been six
months in the making,
but I'm here because of
that chef right there.
So, all right, what
are we doing here day?
I'm Jet Tila.
Let me give you short and
dirty bio-- am I in trouble?
No I'm not, OK.
Let me give you the
short and dirty CV.
I was really fortunate.
I was born into the first Thai
food family in America, right?
My family immigrated here
in the '60s from Thailand
by way of China.
So ethnically, I am
Chinese by way of Thailand.
We opened the first Thai
market, Thai restaurant,
Thai import company,
Thai produce company
in the history of this country.
So every Thai dish
today in America
ties directly back to my family.
So, birth luck.
It's all it was, man.
It's all it was.
From then on in my early 20s,
I dropped out of high school
to go to culinary school.
And I've worked for
some phenomenal people.
So the short accolades are, I
was the Asian executive chef,
Asian dining encore for Nguyen.
I was at Mountain View.
I opened the first Asian cafe
called the Pacific Cafe like
in '04 at Google Mountain View.
I've got five world records
under my belt, do a ton of TV.
I don't tell you this
to toot my own horn.
I tell you this to
put you at ease.
You are with the guy.
You know the other
guys that sometimes you
go to demos you see, and you're
like, that's not the guy.
I'm the guy, all right?
I'm that guy.
First of all, before we get
rolling, let's stay in touch.
It's @jettila.
You can just search Jet Tila.
I'm not douchey and put
"chef" in front of my name.
Except for my website, because
I couldn't get jet.com.
Someone jacked it already.
So for the website,
it's Chef Jet.
But everything else
is just Jet Tila.
Instagram, Facebook, Twitter.
And I'm accessible.
So if you guys need a
recipe, if you need advice,
where to eat Thai
food, I'm that guy.
So let me know.
Dialogue, OK?
It's not a monologue.
Let's talk.
If you you guys have any
questions, let me know.
We're doing two of my
favorite dishes today.
One is Pad Thai.
Pad Thai is this
mystical, magical dish
in which when I hire new cooks,
I ask them to fillet a fish,
I ask them to bone a
chicken-- sounds dirty--
and I ask them if they
say they know Thai food.
Because that's either going to
be the last thing you're ever
going to say to me,
or I find a rock star,
you're going to make Pad Thai.
Theoretically pretty simple.
But there's so many
intricacies in this dish
that it's like making pancakes.
You are going to jack up
and burn your first one.
I guarantee you.
But the more you
make it, the more
you start to understand
the nuances, OK?
So we'll do Pad Thai today.
And then, we're going
to do drunken noodles.
Drunken noodles will
soon overtake Pad Thai,
I think, in one of the most
popular Asian noodle dishes
in America.
We're about three to four
years out, in my opinion.
So this is like chicken
and waffles, right?
And this is like Suvi chicken
that's been boned out,
ballantine.
One more time?
AUDIENCE: It's going to
be chicken and waffles.
JET TILA: Yeah, exactly.
That's exactly right.
But a waffle crisp, OK?
So that's where we're going.
All right, so let's talk
about Asian food really quick.
Let's break it down.
Who cooks?
Who wants to actually learn
how to cook something today?
Who just wants to
be entertained?
Who wants a little of both?
OK, all right, I got you.
I always ask that question
because I would give you
just the hey, that
was really fun,
I'm never going to cook
anything version of this thing.
But you guys want to
really do this, right?
OK.
There's a three letter
word in Thai food
that sums up the perfect balance
point between four flavors.
What is that three letter
word that starts with Y?
AUDIENCE: Yum.
JET TILA: Yum.
The white people beat you, dude.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
Is anyone easily offended?
Because I'll tone it down.
Who says keep going?
Am I OK?
OK, great.
Yum.
It's not like yummy
in my tummy yum.
It's a real Thai word, and it
means the perfect balance point
between hot, sour, salty, sweet.
You master four flavors
in Thai cooking,
you understand it, right?
What is the yum?
It's simply these
things right here.
That's it.
That's the yum.
It's not as magical
mystical as you think.
So let's break it
down by flavor,
and you'll start to
understand the yum, OK?
So pick a flavor.
Pick one of the four.
Let's go there.
Sweet.
What is the first ideal sweet?
Sugar.
Cane sugar, beet sugar,
palm sugar, I don't care.
But there's this
other ingredient
that we use as sweet.
This is called sweet soy sauce.
60/40 black strap
molasses to soy sauce.
So it's extremely sweet.
Way more sweet than salty.
And because it's molasses,
it coats food amazingly.
It sticks to that food,
makes it really dark.
If you ever eat Pad See-ew
in Thai food or dark soys,
that's the secret.
Oh man, I should charge
you for this class.
Look at that, you're
learning so many things.
I love it.
Sweet soy, sugar.
If you're cooking
at home and you
don't want to buy
palm sugar, do you
want like-- do you guys
like-- I'm a food nerd.
Who wants to food
nerd out with me?
Do you want to talk
about palm sugar?
Again, the break and the gas.
You guys drive, OK?
Palm sugar, yes?
Who wants to learn
about palm sugar?
OK, yes.
I'm a coconut palm tree.
I'm a dwarf coconut palm
tree obviously, all right?
Before the nuts
actually develop,
I sprout shoots
of flowers, right?
These flower will
eventually become nuts.
If you gathered these
bunches of shoots,
and you tied them
together and cut off--
if you cut my fingers
off, I bleed, right?
The tree bleed sap.
So the sap from the
coconut palm tree
is called fresh coconut juice.
Reduce that liquid into a solid,
guess what you've just created?
Very good. palm sugar.
You're absolutely
correct, all right?
So, yeah, you knew
that shit, dude.
I'm sorry.
OK, so palm sugar is
the reduction of what?
AUDIENCE: Coconut.
JET TILA: That was too easy.
I'm not going to give
a gift for that one.
OK, got you.
Perfect.
All right, sweet.
Sweet.
Pick another flavor.
Go.
AUDIENCE: Sour.
JET TILA: Sour.
We have a few twists
and turns now, right?
The number one sour in Thai
cooking is going to be this.
Persian limes is the
common lime that we
use in American, not key lime.
Too small, a lot of work.
Really kind of a stringent.
Too acid for me.
Persian limes.
Real lime, not that crap that
comes in a plastic lime that
says "real lime," all right?
That's one acid.
Your second acid
is vinegar of rice.
Make sense.
Your third acid is tamarind.
Oo, ah, what is tamarind?
It's this potted fruit
that grows anywhere
around the equator.
Started in Africa.
It's traveled the world into
Latin America, in India, right?
In Asia.
So tamarind juice.
You take the fruit from
the tamarind, you seed it,
you take the shell
away, you mix it
with water to make
a cooking liquid,
and you've made
cooking tamarind.
Or, you go to Bangkok
market and you buy it.
That's it, am i right?
Last flavor.
Oh, I have two more.
Go.
What's my next flavor?
AUDIENCE: Salty.
JET TILA: Salty.
I'll do salty, then
I'm going to do spice.
For Thai cooking,
guys, fish sauce
is going to be 95% to
98% percent of your salt.
We are not European chefs.
We don't go here.
This is salt.
In French, Italian,
that's salt, right?
Salt is already in
here with the addition
of anchovies and water.
So we're using this
as a salt, but also
gives you a layer
of umami, right?
There's glutamates, that kind
of full-flavored taste as well.
So that's salt.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JET TILA: Fish sauce.
You're using fish sauce.
And because a lot of us
Thai people are Chinese,
we're also going to
be using soy sauce.
Because we've already
learned about sweet soy, OK?
Everyone raise your right hand.
I swear--
AUDIENCE: I swear--
JET TILA: --to never use--
AUDIENCE: --to never use--
JET TILA: --Kikkoman--
AUDIENCE: --Kikkoman--
JET TILA: --in the Thai kitchen.
AUDIENCE: --in the Thai kitchen.
JET TILA: OK, OK, you pass.
All right, you pass, all right?
Use Chinese soys and use
Thai fish sauces, period.
All right?
Good to go.
Missing--
AUDIENCE: --soy sauce.
JET TILA: What is
Chinese soy sauce?
AUDIENCE: What's the brand?
JET TILA: Lee Kum Key,
Golden Mountain, Healthy Boy,
I can go on all day.
Yeah, yeah, just remember
the brand not to use.
I don't hate Kikkoman.
I love Kikkoman when I'm
cooking Japanese food.
I don't use Kikkoman
when cooking Thai food.
All right, let me
make that very clear.
And the last salt and
savory together is
Oyster sauce.
This is your one-cook wonder.
This is the one sauce you take
into a cooking competition
if you have one ingredient.
Because it has all the
flavors we mentioned.
It has umami.
It has sweet.
It has salt in it.
It's an amazing sauce.
For the hot, I'm either using
fresh chillies or chili sauce.
This is sriracha.
That other BS with the
green cap with the rooster
is not sriracha.
That's American, Vietnamese,
Chinese sauce called sriracha.
Sriracha is a province in the
southern coast of Thailand
that grows chillis.
This sauce has those chillies,
and it's from Thailand.
So expand your
minds a little bit
and buy sriracha from
Thailand, for God's sake, OK?
AUDIENCE: What's
one of those bands?
JET TILA: What's
one of those brands?
This is a good brand.
This is actually PK brand,
or Grand Mountain brand.
This is a phenomenal brand.
Thai sriracha is more
garlic-y and Umami.
That other stuff-- that's only
good for pho and spicy tuna
rolls, by the way-- is
very vinegar, is very acid.
So this plays with
food so much better.
OK?
Should we cook?
You guys read to do this?
All right, I've given
you enough lecture.
No more lecture.
You have any, like,
bowls and stuff?
All right, so let's make sauce.
Pad Thai sauce.
First of all-- oh,
you know, I'm just
going to cook off the cuff.
I'm going to be wild
and crazy today, OK?
Yeah, I'll do that.
Perfect.
OK.
This looks like a
lot of ingredients.
Do not let it scare
you, all right?
And if you guys
want to get closer,
if you want to hang
out back here with me,
you want to stand outside
not blocking anyone,
I mean, this is your house, bro.
It really is.
So if you want to be-- you
want to be, like, right here
hanging out with me,
just come on back.
Come on.
Some of you do.
I know you want.
You want to bring a chair?
Do you want to bring
a chair with you?
You sure?
You want a big chair?
OK.
I just wanted to
make sure you're OK.
All right, sounds good.
All right, all
the way over here.
Come over, come over, come over.
I'll take bowls.
Give me that bowl
without the eggs.
There you go.
Look at that.
See, no one's ever done that.
Now he's freaking out, dude.
The camera's like, oh my god.
What the hell am
I going to do now?
Oh my god.
OK, I think about
things in flavors.
I don't think about
them as ingredients.
Does that make sense?
So cooking is a lot--
a lot of people in here
are good at math.
So I was a pretty
decent at math.
I cook in ratios.
I'm going to make a Pad
Thai sauce in ratios.
Shall we do that together?
Thinking yum and
thinking ratios.
So, first I'll
probably think of is,
I need a sugar salt balance.
So remember, I'm cooking for 30.
So this looks like
a lot of sugar.
But it's actually not that bad.
So I'm thinking about a sugar
salt ratio of one to one
first of all, OK?
So salt being this, fish sauce,
sugar being sugar-- and you
could have gone to brown.
You could have gone to palm.
You could have gone to
anything you want, OK?
So sugar-- sugar, salt.
Acid to these two.
You probably only need
about 25% to 30% acid.
You don't want it
extremely acid, OK?
Because salt and
acid play together,
and they actually
bring each other up.
So--
AUDIENCE: So that's
the tamarind?
JET TILA: This is tamarind.
So maybe 20% to 30%.
Does that makes sense?
OK.
Do I need heat now?
Absolutely do you need heat now.
Sriracha.
But we know good
sriracha also brings
glutamates, which is
umami, brings heat,
brings a little
more acid to that.
And I've kind of made
the base Pad Thai sauce.
If you want to get--
AUDIENCE: If you see that
that was like 40% sweet,
40% [INAUDIBLE]--
JET TILA: Yeah, I would say--
AUDIENCE: 20% tamarind--
JET TILA: I would say--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JET TILA: Now I'm just confused.
I don't know what
you're saying now.
You know what
we've done for you?
We have a recipe.
Yeah.
Thank chef over there.
Chef made the recipe.
Thank chef.
So you have a recipe, OK?
But those of you--
who hates recipes?
Who tries to cook by feel?
Right, just say it.
Just be honest.
Thank you, exactly, all right?
So that's why I'm
giving you ratios.
So that was about
30% acid, right?
So I need to complete that
30% with a little bit of rice
vinegar.
Because there are
little layers of acid.
Does that make sense?
Not all acid tastes the same.
Even though the acidities
might be the same,
the flavors are
different, right?
And then next time,
I want you to raise--
everyone raise your
right hand again.
I swear--
AUDIENCE: I swear--
JET TILA: --to taste as I cook.
AUDIENCE: --to taste as I cook.
JET TILA: Thank you.
Amen.
Even if the recipe is
spot-on, maybe you're
using a different fish sauce.
Maybe you're using,
like, a different-- you
know what I mean?
A different flavor,
different brand
that I'm not endorsing
or believe it.
No, I'm kidding.
So anyway, the last bit is
going to be in the cooking.
So I've made a basic
Pad Thai sauce, OK?
Let's start cooking
Pad Thai, shall we?
Order of operations.
This is some wok technique now.
Whatever takes longer
to cook goes in later.
Whatever it takes longer
to cook goes in first.
I'm sorry.
I went the other way.
Yeah, I know.
I forgot, I'm talking
to smart people.
If I was like,
[MOCK CONVERSATION]
oh yeah, totally.
Yeah, the longer it takes,
the sooner it goes in.
You start with a good oil.
You never use olive oil
ever in Asian cooking, OK?
And you never start looking
until you see white smoke.
Do we see--
AUDIENCE: What's a good oil?
JET TILA: I'm sorry.
JET TILA: Peanut,
canola, sunflower,
any high-temp low-flavor oil.
Baked tofu.
Dried shrimp.
AUDIENCE: Baked tofu, you said?
JET TILA: Baked tofu.
Dried shrimp.
Pickled daikon red.
Thai-style, not Japanese
or Korean-style.
Thai-style.
Garlic.
I'm like, huh, how
many am i cooking for?
I better put more in there.
OK, so-- and I don't
really cook for time.
Because I don't know
how hot your cooktop is.
I cook by smell.
You starting to smell that?
Is that fragrant?
Is it fragrant and not burning?
Absolutely.
So now, I want to
cook eggs in here.
So I want to put this--
I add oil as I need.
I don't like pools of oil,
to be honest with you.
So now I'm going
to add some eggs.
And this is how I
cook eggs in the pan.
I distribute them around-- out.
And I break the
yokes, and I start
to let them coagulate
and set, all right?
Don't hurry the scramble.
Because you want to
really be able to ID
the whites and the yolks.
And then, once they
start to coagulate,
you drag the other
aromatics through,
and they all play
together beautifully.
See how that works there?
So basically, I'm
starting with--
AUDIENCE: I smell
how that works.
JET TILA: You smell that?
Isn't that delicious?
And now I'm doing a
little bit of chicken,
or you can do shrimp.
Whatever you want.
But I'm doing chicken today.
Now my chicken, I'm always
marinating my proteins first.
It's very simple marinade.
This will be a quiz.
You'll get a gift for this one.
Lubrication is a little oil,
cornstarch to suck moisture
into the chicken, baking soda
to denaturize and tenderize,
and salt for flavor.
I'm only going to
tell you that once.
Who can repeat
that-- ah, too late.
I'm going to let you
forget that first.
And then I'll come back there.
All right, so you notice
I'm scraping as I go.
And nothing is sticking, but
I'm still hearing a sear.
That starting to smell good?
Questions so far.
No?
If you're cooking
for a party, how
do you do it if
you're into catering?
Everything I just put in there
can be cooked right through
and then cooled--
This is a good how
do you cook Pad
Thai for 50 people--
and then held that way.
So in a restaurant, I get a
ticket, pick up Pad Thai, boom.
And then I can start
from this phase.
Does that make sense?
It's a very efficient
way to cook Pad Thai.
You're like, I don't care, man.
I'm cooking for four.
Shut up.
OK, here we go.
My proteins are
about 80% cooked.
I can continue.
Because I don't want to
cook my proteins 100%
because I still have a few
more things to put in there.
Noodles.
This is rice stick.
Dry rice noodle
made in Thailand.
Not Thai sticks, rice sticks.
You're in trouble.
I always wait for the laugh,
because that person's busted.
If you don't know what
I'm talking about,
better you for it.
Google it.
Google it right now.
OK, so rice sticks have
soaked in warm water
for about 40 minutes.
Keeping them in water,
I'm pulling them out.
Because once that residual
moisture hits the pan,
it creates what?
AUDIENCE: Steam.
JET TILA: And I need that.
I need that steam, right?
And these rice sticks come in
different sizes by millimeter.
This is a small, which is
about a two millimeter.
And they go all the way
up to eight millimeter.
I like the two--
smalls and mediums.
Don't go any crazier than that.
All right, so the
noodle needs to morph.
It needs to steam.
It needs to sear.
So we're going to keep an
eye on this new noodle.
And you're going to
help me determine
when to put the sauce in.
Because if I put the sauce
in now, I'm boiling noodles.
I'm not getting that beautiful
steamed chewy mouth feel,
right?
AUDIENCE: This is
the trickiest part.
I've never--
JET TILA: This is the
hardest, hardest part.
AUDIENCE: This is
where I always mess up.
JET TILA: And also because
if you go thicker noodles,
it takes longer.
So, do you want another
secret tip for Pad Thai?
If you had a little bit of
boiling water on the side,
you dip these for literally
one second up and down,
throw them into the
pan, that will give you
that nice chewy mouth feel.
AUDIENCE: So even--
JET TILA: You've expedited.
AUDIENCE: So what you're
saying, even after you've
soakied some noodles in
the water for a while,
you go back another [INAUDIBLE]?
JET TILA: Such a
fast dip, right?
And another thing,
if your home stoves--
if you're at this point and
you don't hear this-- everyone
listen.
If you don't hear that sizzle,
your pan is way out of temp.
It's too cool.
And your noodles
will never get there.
So that's why you do
your speed dip, OK?
So is it changing?
What do we notice
about these noodles?
AUDIENCE: They look like they're
going to get all sticky on you.
JET TILA: They almost
look cooked, don't they?
Now I know I'm ready for sauce.
Because we needed
them to change.
And again, this is the hardest
part about Pad Thai right here.
All right, sauce.
In Thailand, old school
Pad Thai 40 years ago
was not nuclear orange in color.
It came to America--
AUDIENCE: With ketchup, right?
JET TILA: Ah.
Well, I mean, I don't know
how Tommy Tang does it.
I'm kidding.
But yes, you are
absolutely right.
In America, when we started
doing this about 40 years ago
in the restaurant, we're
like, American people
don't eat spice.
What we do to give
them that little pop?
Little bit of paprika.
But in Thailand, you
don't do paprika.
You go to sriracha, right?
So you have the choice
is what I'm saying.
If you're cooking for
the little kiddies,
I would not put the
sriracha or the chili.
I would do a little
bit of paprika just
to give it some interest.
You see that color?
It really builds
in a nice color.
Was that last thing we swore on?
What did we swear?
Taste as you go, guys.
This is a perfect op to taste.
Because you're going to
know now, like, well dude,
did I put enough sauce in?
Did I put enough paprika in?
AUDIENCE: Where I
mess up is the noodles
will start to break apart--
JET TILA: Yes
AUDIENCE: --added
too much sauce for--
JET TILA: Yes.
Another thing you
might be doing too
is you're putting the
sauce in too early.
If the noodles cook through,
they become very tough, right?
Yeah, they become a little on
the tough-- in a pleasant way.
Now, because the American
expectation of Pad Thai,
is a little sweet, I would tend
to lean to that sweet side.
I like that sweetness
in Pad Thai.
It's one of the few dishes that
it's OK to be a little sweet.
So the noodles are
about 75%, 80% done.
Here's is our last phase.
A mixture of scallions.
Two inch sliced scallions
and some Julian scallions.
I really like that look.
Peanut.
We roasted these
peanuts ourselves,
crushed them ourselves.
And a little bit of bean sprout
on and a little on the side.
So I'm just going to tuck all
those ingredients together.
Let them steam together
so that bean sprouts
yield a little bit,
the scallions loosen up
that really strong flavor
and sweeten up a little bit.
Let me tell you a trick.
Your last trick.
Let's all acknowledge and admit
that the Italians stole pasta
from Chinese people.
Let's get it out of the way.
So the secret of using pasta
water to get a little tight,
like, a nice glaze--
that was Chinese, yo.
That was Chinese, OK?
I'm going to do a
little more paprika,
and I'm going to
finish this dish.
Questions on Pad Thai yet?
You're going to eat this, so--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JET TILA: How sensitive is--
AUDIENCE: What we're cooking.
JET TILA: Oh, very,
very sensitive.
Your gauge-- you have two
primary gauge-- or things
you don't want to over cook.
One is the protein.
Two is the noodle.
So as long as you
put your noodles
in when the chicken isn't
totally dust and dry,
that's the first good.
And second, as you start
to feel this dish, when
the noodles overcook,
they'll actually break down.
Can I have the
black plate please?
Right?
Does that make sense?
So I'm going to play
it up, and just one
how I want you to plate this.
And in the rest, we'll
just do portions.
So I'm cutting this lime not
down the core of the middle.
I'm going off to
one side, right?
I think this is the
cutting surface.
I think chef just,
like, lost his mind.
He was like, don't cut on that!
Don't cut on that!
All right, so this is-- I'll
plate the portion that-- when
you're cooking on a
date, this is how you're
going to play it up, all right?
If you're already married,
then just give it a plate.
Who cares?
OK, I'm kidding.
So, I know.
What a jerk.
What a jerk, right?
So the noodles on the bottom.
Don't forget your
nice proteins on top.
Leave some negative space.
Because you eat with
your eyes, right?
And then, I'm going to engineer
this dish a little bit.
So I need to call
out a few things.
I need to call out bean
sprout on one side.
I left a good amount of
negative space for bean sprouts.
I'm such a nerd,
it's not even funny.
I had to pretend to
be cool in school
because I was such a nerd.
I'm going to call out lime,
in case you need more lime.
And I'm going to call out
peanut on this kind of tucked
into the side.
And then, I'm going to do
a little peanut on top.
And then I'm going to call
out a little bit of scallion.
So there you go.
That is the dish
pre-marriage, and here's
the dish post-marriage.
Dinner's ready!
But this is like, hon,
I really like you.
I'll cook like this forever.
No you won't.
Yeah.
OK, so Julie on the side here
is going to dish this out.
Thanks, guys.
Thank you very much.
All right, questions?
Yo.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
an order of operations
when you're doing shrimp?
JET TILA: Uh, yeah.
The order of
operations on shrimp
is, does shrimp cook faster
or slower than chicken?
AUDIENCE: Faster.
JET TILA: Then put it right
in right before the noodles.
Put it in at the same time,
but don't let it cook as long.
Does that makes sense?
Let the eggs be more cooked.
OK, just mind your protein.
I'm going to grab that
pan right behind you.
You're good.
Don't-- everyone's just freeze.
You're better off not moving
and getting in my way, OK?
Questions?
AUDIENCE: If you were going
to [INAUDIBLE] with fire--
JET TILA: Oh yeah,
so just lay them out.
People can grab their own.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How would the fire be?
JET TILA: How would the fire be?
Phenomenal question.
This is how I cook, OK?
So I only can speak for myself.
I let that fire rip.
My heat is always
on full maximum.
I control my heat by
putting ingredients in,
not by doing this.
Oh my god, it's on.
No, it's off.
No, it's on.
Because you know why?
You'll forget.
You'll forget that it's on,
and you're be like, damn it.
I've lost my sear.
So that technique takes
a little time to master.
But that's how I
cook, and that's
how I teach my chefs to cook.
When we're in the restaurant,
first thing before service
starts, I rip all my burners.
They're just all on fire.
And I had to temps of
oven in the kitchen.
Max like 400 or 500 degrees,
or like 300 degrees.
I have two temps, and that's it.
This is my control right here.
This is it, OK?
Questions?
Pad Thai?
Let's go to the next.
The next one's a little easier.
OK, what you need to
learn about this dish.
Julie is going to be passing
around, so don't be shy.
Because we're a family.
Let's just circulate.
Eat.
This team over here.
Oh wait, yeah, beauty shots
for Twitter, Instagram.
@jettila, @jettila, @jettila,
@jettila, all right?
Pad Thai does not hold well.
So it's one of the things--
rip it and get it out
within a few minutes.
Like, [SNAPS FINGERS] Not a
good dish to take to potluck.
What is cool about Pad Thai
is, bring it in pieces,
cook it there, and you
look like a rock star.
So remember that cook all
the proteins together.
So bring all your
proteins cooked.
Bring your noodles.
And then bring your garnishes.
Just three different, like,
Tupperware containers.
You need a skillet, you need
oil, and you're jamming.
And all of a sudden, they're
like, hey, what's your number?
All right, I'm going to make
sauce for drunken noodles.
New noodle to learn.
What were those noodles called?
AUDIENCE: Rice sticks.
JET TILA: Who said that first?
Who said that first?
Rice sticks, yay.
What was that other trivia
question that I had?
What was that really
difficult one?
Go.
You should have
raised your hand.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] salt.
JET TILA: Oh, pick your poison.
You want fish
sauce or sweet soy?
AUDIENCE: Sweet soy.
JET TILA: Go.
Sweet soy.
That's you, all right.
There will be more prizes.
OK, new noodle.
This will be a trivia
question later on.
In English, these are
fresh rice noodles.
In Chinese, we call them ho fun.
Ho fun, OK?
In Thai, oh, they're sen yai.
Wide noodles, all right?
So let's see if you remember
all three of those, OK?
They come in the deli section.
Non-refrigerated, room temp,
only good for about 24 hours.
They're circulated out every 24.
The test on whether
they're fresh or not is
you grab the pack, do this.
And if they bend
without breaking,
this is a fresh bloody noodle.
The secret of bringing
this noodle back,
though, in the
restaurant setting,
fridge them immediately
fresh, throw them
in the steamer in the bag.
It's kind of like suvi.
And let them come
back up in the steamer
in the bag, which is
what we did today.
Because these were
bought three days ago.
But this is how you
get them back, OK?
At Wazuzu, my restaurant
at Win Las Vegas,
we did 150 to 250 orders
a day of this dish.
Each dish had a pound
of noodles in it.
You don't even want to know
what the calorie count is.
Don't ask.
Let's make sauce.
Pad Thai is very Thai.
Drunken noodles is a
hybrid of Thai and Chinese.
We can pick into that, guys.
Don't be shy.
All right, if it was me,
I'd be jamming into that,
so-- let's build
this sauce together.
Oyster, because it's
the Chinese roots.
Yeah, here, put it over here.
Get it on my face, man.
Come on, put it over there.
I'm kidding.
Why are you in my way, man?
I'm getting kidding, I'm
kidding, I'm kidding.
Oyster.
What flavor is that?
What flavor's oyster?
Everything, basically, right?
Everything.
Fish sauce.
Salt.
And I've got to make
enough for all of us.
Heat.
Your real sriracha.
Real sriracha here.
Renee, take this with you.
That's my gift to you.
There you go.
All right, I need a
little sugar for sweet.
AUDIENCE: What's
your favorite sugar?
JET TILA: Uh, I got to tell
you, if I'm not being fussy,
in every restaurant I've
ever operated in America
without buying palm, I use
brown sugar all day long.
Light brown sugar.
AUDIENCE: How do you
get so it doesn't stick?
JET TILA: The brown sug--
oh, there's a million things.
You put like a little--
what do you put in there.
Like a little disk of
clay or whatever that is.
I've never let it
sit long enough.
AUDIENCE: Oh, if it's
airtight, it won't--
JET TILA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --they
won't, you know.
And also, you can put a piece
of white bread in there.
JET TILA: White bread.
AUDIENCE: And it-- totally.
The bread comes
out like dry toast.
But like 24 hours
later, your sugar
is totally like powdered sugar.
JET TILA: So I'm
not going to lie.
A lot of restaurants--
we're not using this today--
do add a little bit
of chicken powder.
The Chinese secret to umami is
adding a little chicken powder
to this.
And you're like, what
is chicken powder?
Bullion cubes.
You guys know what
I'm talking about?
That gives you so much
umami pop for a dish.
So if you're ever
cooking at home,
and you're like, that doesn't
taste like the restaurant,
they're probably
putting in a little bit
of MSG, a little bit
of chicken powder.
Just so you know.
I'm just being brutally
honest with you.
OK, sauce is done.
Delicious.
Tip-- if you take the recipe
and you're like, dude,
I'm going to do this all
the time-- because you
know how you get that
recipe and you do it, like,
once a week for
like three weeks,
and then it becomes
once a month,
once every five years?
Take the recipe of sauce only,
multiply that by 5 or 10 or 20,
and put it in a squeeze bottle.
And look really cool
when you cook, OK?
Don't do this every
time you want to cook.
If you love a recipe, up
multiply it one time, OK?
All right, let's do this.
Chef here loves you so much.
We use rice bran oil.
That's like adamantium
or like diamond dust,
you know what I mean?
Like, he's using, like,
the-- I'm such a nerd.
I'm going to shut up now.
OK, so what am I looking for?
All right, garlic,
aromatics, stay still.
Can we eat spicy here?
Anyone scared?
No?
All right.
Onion.
How many am I cooking for?
OK.
Onion.
Chili.
What, you wimping out on me now?
I'm kidding.
I've got some-- basically
cherry tomatoes.
Grape tomatoes work
really well too.
And now I've got protein.
Don't breathe in the smoke
if you are chili sensitive.
I've just made chili smoke.
[FAKE COUGHS] I'm
kidding, I'm kidding.
I'm kidding.
OK.
Now I'm going-- It's nice
to have a nice, wide cooking
surface.
I think I've just proven
these are pretty bad-ass.
You can buy one of these,
and they work really well.
OK, so, because they're
not in a blazing hot wok,
I might do this
one in two steps.
Because I want that beautiful
kind of wok fire taste,
I'm going to cook this down,
separate it out, and then start
the noodles separately.
If I was doing just like
one to four portion,
I would do it all in this pan.
But because I'm doing so
much, I'm not going to.
I'm going to do two pans.
OK, there we go.
That pan's going
to heat up again.
Rice bran oil.
I'm going to, like, jack
some and take it home.
It's such nice oil, it's crazy.
All right, so what
am i waiting for?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JET TILA: Very good, guys.
Very good.
Best tip so far that you're
going to take with you.
Just fire one off.
Best tip, best
cooking tip so far.
AUDIENCE: Taste your food.
JET TILA: Taste your food.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Keep the noodles wet.
JET TILA: Keep noodles wet.
Very good.
So remember my
technique for eggs.
I don't pre-scramble.
I hate that.
Doesn't look professional to me.
I break yolks.
I allow to coagulate.
Do I dare?
Yes, Yes, it's not
freaking out on me.
99.
We're going all the way, dude.
We're going all the way.
Those eggs are going
to come out faster
than that because of
this induction burner.
It's a Great burner.
OK, so the eggs are
starting to coagulate.
And I really love
that separation
between yolk and white.
It's so important to me.
I want to sear my noodles now.
That's fresh right there.
That's super fresh.
And these come pre-oiled.
They come actually from the
factory with a little oil,
or they would stick like crazy.
Are we going to feed-- oh yeah.
You guys will eat it all.
I don't think I made
enough Pad Thai.
If you do want to
hang right after this,
I'll make another
quick batch of Pad Thai
because I have all those
proteins ready to go.
OK.
So with these noodles, I want
them to get that sear love.
So I'm not going to rush them.
I'm not going to rush them.
I'm going to let them sear up.
And I like how the eggs
are going to marry well.
Crank that other
pan up back there.
Let's just get that going.
And we could split the
task and get some heat.
Questions so far?
Is this anything like
you did the other night?
AUDIENCE: No, I
misspoke. [INAUDIBLE].
JET TILA: What's that?
AUDIENCE: We had
done the Pad Thai.
JET TILA: Oh, you
did Pad Thai, OK.
Very difficult, isn't it,
to do really good Pad Thai?
AUDIENCE: I don't think I got
the right noodles [INAUDIBLE].
JET TILA: Oh really?
AUDIENCE: --in getting
[INAUDIBLE] together.
JET TILA: You got
right noodles now.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JET TILA: All right.
When that pan gets screaming,
put oil in it and let me know.
You're going to cook half of
this over there, all right?
Questions about anything
cooking related?
One more time.
White and black vinegar.
Flavor?
Black vinegar is very almost
like balsamic-tasting.
It's got a fruit note to it.
Like a deep-- almost
like a plumb note.
Good for dipping, not
really for cooking.
Good for souping and
good for dipping.
Good questions.
Any other question?
OK.
So, you screaming?
You'll get there.
All right, Pad Thai.
Thought?
Comments?
That good?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JET TILA: Can you
do that at home now?
AUDIENCE: Yes, [INAUDIBLE].
JET TILA: Totally could.
How do you know when
they're done-- then
what I'm looking for here?
I am looking for-- you know
what raw dough feels like?
And then you know what--
when you take raw dough
and bake it in the oven, it
becomes bread or something?
I'm looking for the edges
to get slightly more opaque.
The dough will get
opaque, and the dough
will get that crust to it.
That's what I'm looking for.
Best analogy i can come up with.
Pretty damn good analogy.
I'm going to remember that one.
OK, so you're going
to do this, Julie.
I'm going to give
you half of this.
The old switcheroony.
I'm going to give her
half of my noodles.
I'm going to steal
half of this protein.
I need that because
we were overwhelming
this cooking surface
with products.
So I'm not getting-- I'm
not allowing the sear.
Here you go.
Take that with you.
All right.
You really don't want more than
about, let's say, 60% to 65%
volume, or you're going
to lose your sear.
So now I've got a
good sear happening.
I'm really going to take
this where I want it.
Yeah, check it out.
Come hang out.
Next ingredient.
Thai basal.
What is-- who's never
smelled it by itself?
Don't give it back to me.
I don't want it.
Just pick a-- pick-- here,
take this out there with you.
Pick a leaf.
Don't-- save your answers until
we all smell this together.
Pick a leaf, pass it on.
It's aroma-therapeutic.
Thai basal.
Product identification.
Purple stem, first
of all, right?
Green leaf.
Kind of this veiny profile.
Smells like, raise your hand.
Smells like?
AUDIENCE: Toothpaste.
JET TILA: Toothpaste.
He's not incorrect.
What is that herb?
Smells like?
AUDIENCE: Mint.
JET TILA: Going to go deeper.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JET TILA: You two.
There you go.
Pick one.
All right, there you go.
Done.
Calm down, calm down.
There you go.
OK, so here we go.
So now, I've got
sear, I've got opaque.
Chicken is 60% to 75% done.
You getting a sear over there?
Good.
You've got time.
I'll do this one
first, you'll catch up.
Chicken.
What was in the
chicken marinade?
Not you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JET TILA: Who answered?
Go.
AUDIENCE: Uh, it was
oil, salt, [INAUDIBLE].
JET TILA: Oh, you win.
All right, I've
got gifts for you.
Perfect, excellent.
All right, here we go.
Sauce.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JET TILA: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: What was
in the sauce again?
JET TILA: Who wants
to raise your hand?
Who remembers
what's in the sauce?
AUDIENCE: Oh god. [INAUDIBLE].
JET TILA: Fish sauce, oyster
sauce, sweet soy sauce,
sriracha.
And now I'm folding.
I'm changing my tools because
the metal now with the moisture
in here will actually
tend to break.
Last secret ingredient.
Chicken bullion.
Basel torn right in.
That is what makes
drunken noodles
different from Pad
See-ew in Thai food.
And I'm not shy.
Like, I've broken off, like,
the really, the lowest, lowest
stems.
I like those upper stems
that are kind of delicate.
I like them a lot.
So I'm actually
including them in.
And that goes in last.
And we're going to basically
cook that leaf down, expose
that essential oil.
And that essential oil will
bleed right into the dish.
And that's what gives this dish
this kind of phenomenal aroma.
AUDIENCE: Is it
[INAUDIBLE] breaking in?
JET TILA: Tom's will be breaking
in now because of the sauce.
So that's why I switched over.
And then the rule.
Remember, Jet Tila's
rule number two.
AUDIENCE: Taste as you cook.
JET TILA: There you go.
Always do that, guys.
Because this is-- before
it hits the plate,
you can mess with it.
You can monkey
with it, all right?
I'm going to just shoot off
the cuff, if you trust me.
AUDIENCE: So why do
you call them drunken?
JET TILA: Drunken
noodles, because what
I didn't add-- here's
the lore of this dish.
It's kee mao.
And if you speak to--
anyone speak Thai?
Kee mao means "the dude
who's an alcoholic."
So this dish is phenomenal
sobering up food.
Yeah.
On TV, though, I have
fudged it a little bit
and added a little rice wine.
But the truth is, you
don't need it at all.
But this is party food.
This is like menudo Saturday
morning, [INAUDIBLE] morning
after partying pretty
hard in the night.
So that's it.
I'm going to plate that up.
Should we do a sexy plate up?
You want me to show
you that date plate?
Date plate?
I'm happy.
Mmm.
All right, date plate.
Here it is.
The date date, first of all.
Then the married
plate after that.
AUDIENCE: All right,
you can see what
happens after you have kids.
JET TILA: Yeah, oh no,
I've got kids, yeah.
Then you order out.
Then you don't cook any
more at home, right?
So a little portion there.
I like call outs.
OK, last time.
I swear--
AUDIENCE: I swear--
JET TILA: I will only use--
AUDIENCE: Only use--
JET TILA: Relevant garnish.
AUDIENCE: Relevant garnish.
JET TILA: Relevant--
this is not relevant.
That's just weird to me.
That's actually a
relevant garnish,
but it doesn't-- that is not
good presentation right there.
So there you go.
You good?
You have sauce?
Hold on.
Questions on drunken noodles.
Who's never had this one before?
Never?
Ok, cool.
All right.
I'll start dishing out.
As you ask questions, we'll
eat, and then we'll bounce.
Who wants more Pad Thai?
All right.
He ain't shy.
Jeff, can you give me
a hand really quick?
We'll start dishing this out.
I'll make another Pad
Thai while we talk.
So guys.
How do you get a hold of me?
What's going on?
You're going to watch
Cutthroat Kitchen Sunday
nights, Food Network.
OK, Guy's Grocery Games.
Chefjet.com is the website.
You guys know Jet Tila
is everything else.
Next season on Parts
Unknown CNN with Bourdain,
I'll be on the Vegas episode.
Because I was there so long,
I know-- I got a lot of homies
in Vegas, so-- but if
you want to hang out
for another pad thai, feel free.
Cool.
Guys, it was an absolute
pleasure cooking
for team Google.
Thank you very much.
Please stay in touch.
Do let me know if I could
be of service in any way.
Jeff, thanks for having me out.
I hope it was beneficial.
I hope you learned something.
Is it good?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you.
JET TILA: There you go.
Tag me in all your photos.
Thank you.
I'm here for photos.
Whatever you need, y'all.